il s'appelait daniel licht il est décédé
le 14 juillet à la prison de terre haute
dans l'indiana à 8h 7h locales d'une
injection létale après plus de 20 ans
dans le couloir de la mort en 1999 cet
ancien suprémaciste blanc avait été
reconnu coupable des meurtres d'un
couple et de leur fille dans l'arkansas
pour le bureau du ministre de la justice
des états unis
le droit a prévalu aujourd'hui daniel
lewis lee a fait face à la sentence
qu'il méritait après avoir reçu le feu
vert tôt mardi matin le bureau fédéral
des prisons a débuté la préparation de
lits pour l'exécution cependant à un
recours de dernière minute de la part de
l'avocat de lies a entraîné un report
supplémentaire
la cour d'appel des états unis a
définitivement rejeté sa demande
ouvrant la voie à son exécution il a été
déclaré mort à 8h07
dans un communiqué l'avocat de daniel
les rues de friedman a qualifié cette
exécution dont 2
selon elle l'homme de 47 ans a été
conduit dans la salle d'exécution avant
même que les derniers recours
administratif contre son exécution n'ait
été traités au cours des quatre heures
qu'il a fallu à ce gouvernement
irresponsable et impitoyable pour
parvenir à ses fins daniel lewis lee est
resté sanglé à un brancard à peine
trente et une minutes après qu'une cour
d'appel ait levé le dernier obstacle à
son exécution à la demande pressante du
gouvernement fédéral
et ce alors que de multiples requêtes
étaient en suspens et 100 en notifier
son avocat il a été exécuté
c'est plus qu'on te que ce gouvernement
est finalement procéder à cette
exécution dans la hâte au milieu de la
nuit alors que le pays dormait
la branche américaine d'amnesty
international s'est dite elle aussi est
scandalisé par cette exécution
nous sommes horrifiés que le
gouvernement fédéral ait procédé à la
première exécution fédéral en 17 ans
allant à l'encontre de la tendance
mondiale à tourner le dos à de la peine
de mort et des 34 états américains qui
l'ont abolie ou qui n'ont pas procédé à
des exécutions au moins au cours des dix
dernières années
l'exécution de daniel il devait
initialement intervenir le 13 juillet la
première
d'une série de quatre programmées par
l'administration républicaine d'ici la
fin août
toutes concernent des hommes notamment
condamné pour meurtres d'enfants par des
tribunaux fédéraux à la suite d'un
recours un tribunal de washington avait
suspendu ces exécutions au motif que
tous les recours déposés n'avait pas été
examinée
mais la cour suprême saisie par le
ministère de la justice a finalement
invalidé ce report estimant que les
condamnés je cite n'avait pas fait le
nécessaire pour justifier l'intervention
à la dernière minute d'un tribunal
fédéral à quatre mois de l'élection
présidentielle américaine est en pleine
pandémie de covile 19 l'administration
trump a donc relancé les exécutions
fédéral une décision à laquelle s'est
opposé l'union européenne l'union
européenne s'oppose fermement à la peine
de mort constamment et en toutes
circonstances c'est une sanction cruelle
inhumaine et dégradante incompatible
avec le droit inaliénable à la vie qui
n'apportent aucune dissuasion efficace
contre les comportements criminels et
qui est irréversible donald trump qui
brigue un second mandat c'est souvent
prononcé pour un recours plus fréquent à
la peine capitale
c'est donc en écho à cette volonté du
président américain que la reprise des
exécutions a été annoncée il ya un an
par le procureur général des états unis
selon les sondages 77 % des électeurs
républicains sont en faveur de la peine
de mort pour les meurtriers